[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
yeah yeah so far many challengers no
winners we put the challenge out we said
try to find a mistake on her show and
they can't do it because we don't make
them
so tonight a fan named Will Huntley says
he thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened during a segment I did with
Dwayne the rock Johnson just a few weeks
ago take a look hey Conan you did a
video recently with Dwayne the rock
Johnson about his new movie rampage
coming out and you were a stunt double
you said earlier in the video that
Zamboni's only drive on ice well they
can drive anywhere because they have
wheels and an engine
sorry Conan
I want to congratulate you the first fan
to shoot your correction from the
birthplace of Betsy Ross and that took a
lot of guts that day I admire your spunk
usually when I receive a fan correction
I just tell the viewer you're dead wrong
but this time I have to admit that in
this very case I don't know if I'm right
or wrong
maybe Zamboni's can drive anywhere so
we're gonna find out now right now my
prop master bill Tull is sitting behind
the wheels of his am Boni on ice bill
can you hear me okay when I say go when
I say go Bill's gonna drive the Zamboni
off the ice and we will have our answer
and we'll all watch it happen together
here we go 3 2 1 go bill go
[Music]
[Music]
I guess he's right : you can drive these
Zamboni's anywhere
my god why are you applauding which you
sick freaks what's wrong with you
bill toe is dead burned alive what a
terrible way to go oh what's that
I've just been fake told that we've
received a posthumous message from our
late prot masterbuilt oh hi Conan if
you're watching this it means I'm dead
you were right all along sambonis are
only meant for the ice as for you we'll
Huntley I'll see you soon
in hell
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway the challenge still stands if do
you think you've supported an era on our
show reported a team koco.com / - Dan
arrow we will sort it out right here on
the air I will take a little break me
come back cover nuts here we'll see you
you